[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 49th
episode of chess trap series
in today's lecture we are going to see a
beautiful trap
in the bogo indian defense from the
white perspective
the opening arises after the following
move order
d4 knight to f6 c4
e6 and if white played the move knight
to c3
then after bishop to b4 he entered into
the nimzo indian territory
which many white player doesn't like it
so the big time alternative is white
continued with
knight to f3 and goes into the sort of
catalan territory
okay here black has some good options
but we are looking at the move bishop to
b for check
known as bogo indian defense
obviously now knight to c3 transposed
back
into the nimso indian territory so the
only independent good move here is
bishop to d2 blocking and same time
attacking and accordingly queen to e7
is a fitting reply
what really black is hoping for
that if a foolish white player continue
with
bishop captures b4 then after queen
captures b4
black queen is attacking two spot and
black get
instantly winning position just within
the opening stage so nope
white shouldn't do it and accordingly
the main line continue with
g3 knight to c6 and bishop to g2
all set to castle on the king side
well in my past i have covered the move
bishop captures d2
where if white continue with queen
captures d2
then it falls into a trapey territory
however after knight b captures d2 the
game remain perfectly balanced
thus the second big alternative for the
black camp
is to castle on the king side and after
a white castle
[Music]
the trappy platform is set right here
guys
black has to be very careful he has to
either chop up this bishop
or continue with d5 but
as per the online database there are 25
plus
free day games continue with knight to
e4
which looks very logical
black is forcing the issue here and
again if you take on b4
then after queen captures b4 black
position
remain better but
guess what this is exactly
where black fallen into the trap
can you identify why this is a big time
mistake by black camp
congratulations if you find the move
bishop to e3
and the idea is very obvious that
now black's poor dark square bishop
is going to trap down in almost
all the lines
well let's look at few of the options
number one queen to e8
trying to give a location for the dark
square bishop
well i'm afraid just one move c5
and in the next few moves black bishop
is a completely corner
so that is right out of the equation
the second move d5 also doesn't work
here
because we will continue with a3
attacking the bishop and now black can
choose
at which square his bishop going to lock
down
for example if bishop to d6
then c5 trapping the bishop
and if bishop goes for the long route
let's say bishop to e5
then after b4 bishop to b6
and the move c5 that poor guy
simply cannot get out
the third option b6 looks very logical
here
because now if you try to play a3 then
bishop can definitely escape
with bishop to d6 but this time around
again white has a wonderful reply
and that is c5
so idea is very obvious we are trapping
down this bishop
with a3 and b4 so black has to take it
with the pawn but again white is not
allowing that bishop to escape
a3 attacking the bishop and black has
two choices
if he continue with bishop to a5
then after d capture c5 once again
we have the threat of b4 and no matter
however black wriggles he is going to
lose a piece as after knight capture c5
indeed b4 is on the agenda
okay what about c captures d4
a counter blow to the white bishop
and now it looks like black bishop is
going to escape
but just one move knight captures d4
and suddenly black to his horror
find out that his two pieces are hanging
and he cannot save both of them
last but not least i think the only move
which can save the bishop is e5
so black has a very nice idea so let's
say if
white continue with a3 then after
e catches d4 and knight captures d4
this time around as the black queen is
covering the e4 knight
black bishop can simply retrieve to c5
square
and now b4 doesn't work here as
d4 knight hangs with the bishop
so that is how black is planning to
escape
his bishop however
after e5 white has an equally
nice reply namely d5
and this time okay we are not going to
trap down the black bishop
but all the lines leads to clear pawn
advantage
to the white camp
first of all we are attacking the c6
knight
and if knight goes anywhere to the
backward square
let's say knight to b8 then after
knight to h4 black has to surrender
the f pawn
why what happens if the knight simply
retrieve back to the f6
here comes the big point as after a3
and bishop to c5 white has a winning
star move in this position
[Music]
i hope you see it right yup
knight to f5 attacking the queen
and now there is no way black queen
can stay in protection of this dark
square bishop
so once she moved anywhere we are going
to nab
that poor black guy
so knight to f6 is completely out of the
equation
black is forced to play f5 here
but after this the task is very simple
yup knight captures f5 attacking the
queen
rook captures f5 and after bishop
captures e4
if you count the material white emerged
with a clear pawn advantage and
even though black managed to escape his
bishop
there is absolutely no compensation
for the loss of porn
last but not least what happens if
black continue with knight to d4
which is probably the only accurate
response here
and in fact one of the higher ranked
game goes
into this direction where what shows us
a clear path how to get a winning
advantage
just within the opening stage
did you find a killer move here
well congratulations if you find this
deciding blow
knight captures e5 bam
the point is very obvious two of the
black knights are hanging
and after some of the forcing moves
queen captures e5
bishop captures d4 white is regaining
back his piece
and not only that after black's queen to
e7
white shows the power of this position
he kick every single black pieces
backwards
first a3
has to go to the d6 square now he plays
f3 another piece goes back
and final jab in the center
yup e4
and sorry but i can't stop laughing here
not only in this position white is clear
pawn up
but just look at white pawn chain
not only black has to deal with the
immediate threads such as
c5 and f4 and e5
but let's say even though if he managed
to parry it
once white pawns start rolling and take
the space
nobody in the world would like to be in
the
black shoes
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trap in the bogo indian
defense
remember if your opponent continue with
this greedy move
knight to e4 punish him with
bishop to e3 and no matter
however black wriggles either
he has to lose a piece or even though
if he find the right continuation with
e5
the end result gives white a clear pawn
advantage
with massive center which is
obviously with the accurate play are
close to
completely winning position
well thank you for watching this video
feel free
to like subscribe and comment and i will
meet you
in my next episode very soon bye
and take care